-Billy, it is always
great to see you.
Thank you
for coming on the show.
I appreciate this.
-Jimmy, I am so happy
to be here.
This is the most immersive Zoom
I've been a part of.
[ Laughter ]
It feels like you guys
are really there.
-No, these are real people!
-All of this stuff.
-This is all real!
Yeah, we're happening!
-This is incredible.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I always love talking to you,
and I was talking
to you backstage,
and you said that you
had some dental work.
-There was --
I don't know if anybody --
Well, I guess everybody
has experienced the last year
or two years differently.
I've experienced a little stress
during this period of time.
And, apparently, the way that
I've gone about managing
that stress is trying to grind
my teeth into powder at night.
And so, I go to the dentist,
and my dentist says, she says,
"Well, I think there's
maybe a little something
going on down there,"
which doesn't sound like
a very technical thing to me.
So I thought,
"Well, there is, yeah.
It's my teeth.
And she says, "No, no,
the bone right there.
I see a little bit of a shadow."
So I said, "Okay. Well,
what should we do about that?"
Like, maybe take a different
picture or touch up the picture?
-Yeah, let's just try it again,
yeah.
Maybe the shadow will go away.
-You touch it up,
you got Photoshop,
any of that stuff will work.
-Yeah, of course, yeah.
-She doesn't have Photoshop,
so she sends me to her brother.
It's a family
dentistry practice --
right around the corner,
by the way --
if you need a referral,
I'll stay afterwards.
[ Laughter ]
They're fantastic.
Meet me afterwards.
Walking distance from here.
-We're doing a podcast
afterwards talking about it.
-And the guy looks at the photo
with the little shadow,
and he says, "I think there
may have to be an extraction."
Now, that's the first time I've
heard that word at the dentist.
-An extraction.
-I think the worst I've done
is a root canal.
-Yeah, I've done a root --
and this tooth already
had a root canal on it so --
Yeah, it was deep territory.
-So, an extraction.
-But I haven't heard
the word extraction --
Well, I --
perhaps when I did the movie
"Charlotte Gray."
I'm doing a plug
for all my films right now.
[ Laughter ]
-Out on blu-ray right now.
-Cate Blanchett.
That's right. She was --
-The Criterion Collection
is coming out.
[ Laughter ]
-Might have to have been
extracted from France,
in occupied France.
-That's correct.
-No, that was not
what this was about.
So he says,
"You're gonna need
an extraction."
And I said, "All right.
Well, can we do that next week?"
And he said, "Sure."
I come in, and he starts
to numb me up, and he --
I was like,
"How many needles
you got over there, boss?
Like, it looks like a lot."
And he goes,
"Well, I'm gonna have to
pull your tooth out
and then scrape out
any infected bone,
so I'm gonna numb you up
for about nine hours."
[ Audience groans ]
"And in order to numb you up
for nine hours,
it could take about 45 minutes
for me to stick needles in there
to shoot your face full of --"
What do they -- novocain.
-Sure.
-Novocain.
And so I said, "All right.
Well, that sounds awful."
[ Laughter ]
And I was waiting for him to
say, "I'm gonna knock you out."
He didn't say,
"I'll knock you --"
He said, "Would you like
a little nitrous oxide?"
And I said, "Well, I have
never had nitrous oxide."
And he said, "Okay. It's fine."
You just put this thing
on your nose, breathe into it,
and see how you feel.
Some people feel a little
claustrophobic, he says.
-You never had nitrous?
-Never had nitrous oxide before.
Big mistake, error in judgment
on my part in life.
[ Laughter ]
So he pulls out
this contraption,
puts it on my thing.
You know, I've got --
Like, it's like the Bane mask
but it's on your nose.
[ Laughter ]
Like it's the worst
D.C. villain everywhere.
It's like,
"Batman, it is my time."
[ Laughter ]
Bane nose is like [high-pitched]
"Batman, it's my time."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. So you get --
-So I got this thing on my nose.
And he goes,
"Do you feel anything?"
And I go, "No."
And he goes, "All right."
And I see him turn
the little knob, and he goes,
"All right, take a slow,
deep breath in."
And I'm like --
[ Breathes deeply ]
And he goes,
"Do you feel anything?"
I'm like, "Well,
this sweet Caribbean air."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-You're off.
You're on vacation, buddy.
-I'm like, "Is that a steel drum
I hear in the background?"
[ Laughter ]
"Let's get a piña colada
and get this party started."
-What were you like?
-I was chatty.
So, he and I talked a lot
because it took the 45 minutes
to get my mouth all numb,
and I learned that he was
a wrestler in college.
[ Laughter ]
Which I actually took
great comfort in,
because I wrestled
in high school,
and it was really hard,
so I thought, "If you did it
in college,
you must be accomplished."
-Yeah.
-It came in handy
45 minutes later when he's got
his foot on my chest
trying to rip out my tooth.
-Oof.
-The funny thing --
This is the funny thing
about getting a tooth out.
Well, with me anyway.
Mine didn't want to come out.
You know, it's been in there
48 years or however long.
It was stubborn, and I got to
see him trying to work on it,
and I'm on the nitrous,
so everything's fun, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-And you're seeing that angle.
-I'm like, "You're having
trouble, aren't you now?
Suckah."
[ Laughter ]
-And he's like,
"No, you're the --"
-He's like,
"I don't want to explain it."
He should have just turned off
the nitrous at that point.
So he pulls it out, and that was
not the end of the procedure.
-No.
-Okay.
It turns out,
when they pull it out,
your whole, like, skull,
that's a resonant chamber,
so you don't just feel it,
but you hear.
So you hear --
[ Audience groans ]
Any of the vocalists over there,
they know your skull
is a resonant chamber.
So I had that reverberating
through my ears
while he starts then drilling
with his hands.
-Whoo!
-So I'm now a bionic man.
I've got a metal -- I'll show
the camera right over here.
-Camera, yeah. Camera one?
-Are you guys ready for this?
[ Audience groans ]
-Wow.
Wait.
What is that?
-That's a titanium implant
at the moment.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you mean --
Oh, you mean behind that?
That's a gold tooth, Jimmy.
You don't have any gold teeth?
-Wow!
Dude, you are like --
You're like Johnny Depp.
You're like
"Pirates of the Caribbean."
-Get yourself a gold tooth.
-Yeah.
-So this -- Yeah,
this will stay in here.
Because, also, they have
to do a bone graft.
"Where does it come from?"
That's my question.
-Bone-graft material?
-Yeah, I got it in my jaw now,
and it only occurred to me
afterwards that I've got
somebody else's bone
in my jaw now.
-Wow!
-Yeah, like, could it be
an animal or...
-It could be.
-Yeah, well, so anyway,
I got to go back to him.
He's gonna pull out
that part of it.
That's exactly the look
I had on my face.
-I had a bone graft of a --
-So, what kind of bone?
-Like a pit bull.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like there's somebody
here who knows better.
-No, it really is.
-It was a pit bull?
We got a pit bull?
-Feel it. You can feel it.
[ Barks ]
-Oh, my --
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Hook, line -- Hook, line,
and sinker right there, buddy.
Hook, line, and sinker.
[ Laughs ]
Hey, um, you --
Hook, line, and sinker, buddy.
Hey, you won the Emmy last year.
Congratulations, by the way.
-Well --
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I would give you every award
if I could.
-No need to mention it.
I feel pretty confident
that's what most of us
will remember 2024.
-Yeah, no.
This is -- you did win the Emmy.
You are phenomenal in this,
and I love the whole show.
-Thank you.
-I love the whole plot of it.
I love the whole story line
of it, but when you came on,
you just -- your acting
is so good,
it's like you're not even
reading lines,
it's like you're making
these lines up.
I go, "Did he write this?"
I mean, you're phenomenal.
-It is the craziest part
I ever read.
It was so exciting,
and I feel so grateful
to Kerry Ehrin and Mimi Leder
and Jen and Reese
and everybody
who allowed me to do it.
It was a really
once-in-a-lifetime --
I'm old enough to know
how lucky I am
when you get a part like that,
and I knew I was --
I do my best not to screw it up.
-You are so good.
I love the --
My favorite scene was you
and Alex -- Jennifer Aniston...
-Yes.
-...singing
"Nothing's Gonna Harm You."
-Because you're a song-and-dance
man yourself, aren't ya?
-When I'm around --
It was just good and, just,
I loved it, man.
You're great.
What's happening in season two?
-Well, season two,
I think, basically --
Well, we started to shoot,
and then, we had to shut down,
because we started shooting
in February out in Los Angeles.
-Oh, wow.
-And then, things got
pretty serious, and so,
they shut down production.
I flew back to New York.
And they rewrote the entire
season to try to, you know,
write about what was happening
in real time.
And the season takes place
right after Alex and Bradley
have disrupted the network
and said,
"We've had enough of this.
We need a change
in the power structure,"
and so, season two is about
how they put the pieces back
together during a pandemic.
-Yep.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Billy Crudup in the new
season of "The Morning Show."
Take a look at this.
-That was pirate television, and
it has no place on our network.
-This really is
The Land that Time Forgot.
All right. Well, I did my best,
but I cannot drag you idiots
kicking and screaming
into the 21st century.
You're just so caught up
in ruling over
your rotten little fiefdom
that you don't even see
the world that has
sprouted up all around you!
All right. Well, enjoy
broadcasting your cave paintings
to the last remaining savages
who are still watching
over-the-air broadcasting.
The rest of the world,
they've moved to the cloud,
and it is [bleep]
gorgeous up there!
-Cory, if you'll excuse us,
we have a television network
we need to fix.
-Well, get out that superglue.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. That's how you do it!
Billy Crudup, everybody!
The new season
of "The Morning Show"
premieres tomorrow
on Apple TV+.